welcome back everyone to the beginner to
Master speedrun episode number 24 I know
it's been over a week since I posted the
previous episode so I do appreciate
everyone's patience have been traveling
a bit as you can maybe tell uh some
dramatic Lighting in the room today but
uh coming into today I'm rated 1227 I
have a new Fresh profile picture from a
time when I was I think 11 or 12 years
old and uh I'm currently on a 79 game
win streak so try and keep it going
today but before we get to the chess I
do want to thank the sponsor of today's
video which is better help so with the
New Year it's a great time to set some
goals you might have concrete goals like
learning some new opening traps or you
might have more abstract goals like
learning how to cope with your emotions
when you lose in 10
moves you might also have non-chest
goals like improving your sleep diet
exercise relationships or all of the
above if you feel like you're in zugang
and you don't know where to start
working with a therapist can really help
you strategize through the complex Game
of Life and put you on the path towards
achieving your goals now this is where
better health comes in they have a
network of over 30,000 therapists it
makes starting therapy so much easier
and far less intimidating better help
lets you have therapy sessions via video
chat phone call or even messaging to get
started all you need to do is fill out a
simple questionnaire and in most cases
you'll be matched and therapist within
48 hours so if you'd like to try
betterhelp and get 10% off your first
month click the link in the video
description betterhelp.com
erren and join the over 4 million people
who have used betterhelp to live a
happier healthier life thanks again to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video and
now let's get back to the chess first
game playing go go
1222 uh let's play
E4 and we'll have a Kings
Pawn and we have a Petrov defense are we
going to see a Stafford Gambit uh I've
encountered the Stafford once so far in
the
speedrun uh but no we actually see the
copycat variation which uh I believe is
also called the
Damiano against Knight takes E4 I mean
queen E2 is like the obvious best move
simply aligning with the
Knight I'm a little bit surprised my
opponent is going into this variation at
this reading
level um now there is a trap which I can
explain after the game
D5 it defends a knight but I'm going to
play
D3 and if the Knight moves then I'll
have discoveries against a black king
like for example Knight F6 I can play
Knight C6 check so we see Bishop D6
that's interesting uh
counterattacking my knight so if I take
and then take and then take and then
take I'm not really winning
anything uh so one move that comes to
mind here is very
simply sacrificing my knight maybe it's
not super simple but the the move is
Knight takes
F7 and then if King takes F7 then I can
take on
e4 and essentially win a pawn is there
any alternative I can actually play
Knight F3 too which I guess I should
have considered sooner uh Knight F3
would win more than a
Pawn Yeah cuz I I unleashed the queen or
unleash the pin I should say and keep
the Knight attacked yeah let's go for
Knight F3 I feel a little bit Rusty with
uh some calculation but yeah this should
win a uh a clean piece although black
might have some compensation uh let's
take the Knight CU a move like Rook
E8 will likely come maybe black will
take here first
and I do have to be very careful here
because if I take the pawn then I get
pinned
so I guess it's a question where to move
the Knight Knight D4 is the most
centralizing there's also Knight to
G5 though Knight G5 feels like it might
get a bit stuck like F5 and then
H6 so I'm looking at Knight D4 yeah
Knight D4 looks fine so a good start to
the game uh winning a piece early on
now trying to cope with Black's
initiative black is attacking the Knight
again so I have Knight B3 I have Knight
B5 I think these are the only two moves
to
consider let's go for Knight
B5 threatening to take the bishop I
wouldn't mind going for trades here yeah
black supports the pawn with Rook E8 but
now I can take the bishop
and then hopefully focus on
development um it's a little bit awkward
my queen on E2 blocking the bishop and I
played this move earlier because of the
tactics but now I do have some
untangling I'm going to start with
Knight
C3 which I think is the most flexible
move Knight is very happy here and then
very likely I can continue with a
move Bishop
E3
and I'm thinking yeah the queen just
wants to slide over I definitely don't
want to take the Knight and allow Lock's
pawns to be controlling so much space so
Queen D2 looks nice keeping C2
defended also making way for the
bishop and yeah very soon I might look
to Castle Queen
side although sometimes like the general
rule is when you're up a
piece you want to keep things as simple
as possible possible if I Castle Queen
side then maybe I'm subjecting myself to
uh Pawn storm like B5
B4 so I'm going to hold off on cast and
queen side and
just develop my final minor piece and
now I'll have the choice rather to
Castle King side or queen side although
here okay Knight F3 very aggressive move
working my king and queen but I can take
this Knight and everything is under
control here
here not sure what my opponent missed
maybe just forgot my Pawn is controlling
the F3
Square otherwise I could have been in
trouble but yeah now I'm very happy to
trade and I'm taking with king I don't
mind losing casting rights generally
when Queens are off the board King
doesn't mind being in the center
although in this case yeah Rook d8 might
be coming so I'll start with Rook
D1 and then look to tuck the king away
on C1
one and this is what we can call
artificial castling where I'll likely
get the castling
setup but I didn't uh didn't actually
Castle in this game and now I'm offering
The Rook
trade so what's the material I have
Knight and Bishop for three
pawns black does have the four on two
majority on the king
side but uh yeah now I can start winning
back some
pawns very nice having the bishop pair
in this
position let's just go
back okay black sacrificing to get the
the past F Pawn but I have the F1 Square
Under full
control uh Rook F1 likely coming
although Rook F1 there is
G4 so black trying to uh to not make
this super easy um I could start with E4
here yeah I think I will start with
E4 just attacking the
bishop and I think the plan is just to
improve my pieces I get my king to
E3 can also off the trade of Bishops
Bishop
F1 yeah if I get black Bishop off the
board then hopefully life will become
more
simple
uh yeah black is going to try G4
here but I have more than enough uh ways
to handle these pawns on the king
side yeah let's use the king especially
in the end game the The King can
be uh an important piece to get into
play and now it's cleanup time on the
king
side okay opponent resigns so pretty
clean game to start things off I do want
to address this opening because I think
this is a very common Pitfall at the
beginner level uh players is just going
with copycat chest and uh a lot of
beginners will play kn6 here which loses
a queen to Knight
C6 so the best move for black is
actually to keep copying and to play the
move Queen to
E7 and this opening was actually
featured a couple years ago at the US
champion ship Grandmaster Wonder leing
played this with the black pieces
against Fabiana Carana and actually
managed to draw the game and the idea is
after Queen takes E4 black is winning
back the Knight with Pawn to D6 and the
Knight is pinned to the queen so there
is some Theory surrounding this line uh
White should be objectively better but
it's not super easy to prove um and if I
continue just going down the rabbit hole
there is kind of a nasty trap that white
should be aware of if white plays D4 to
at least get a pawn for the piece
there's a sequence Knight C6 and if
Bishop F4 black has a very strong move
G5 and if Bishop G3 white has fallen
into the Trap and this position is black
to move and win a piece the move is Pawn
F5 attacking the queen there's no on
assant because the queen is pinned or
the pawn is pinned I should say and F4
is coming so Queen will move F4 traps
the bishop black is for choice
so just a useful thing to know of course
in this game uh my opponent didn't
really know the the theory and after
Pawn D5 yeah thankfully I was able to uh
find the I think the most precise
continuation knight3 win the piece and
then um yeah not blunder my Queen by
taking on e4 but just avoid losing
material simplify develop and um yeah
sometimes this is just what it takes to
win a chest game at this rating level so
let's move on do another
game uh next opponent playing
RVP I am white again play
E4 and this time we have a
scandy and yeah I'm just going to play
the most principled continuation attack
the queen queen D6 is one of the most
common moves uh Queen A5 is probably the
most common um but with the queen on D6
it's not easy to exploit like I don't
want to play Knight B5 or Knight E4 too
soon I'm going to start with Pawn D4
just preparing to develop and yeah very
fluid development for white in this
position and it's really just a question
what squares I want to choose for my
minor pieces I'm going to start with
Knight F3 I think this is the most
flexible move it does allow the pin but
I don't mind that uh I can play Bishop
E2 to I can be a bit more aggressive
with Bishop to
C4 I can also start with H3
first choices
choices I think I'll start with H3 first
pose the question to Black because if
black takes and then I take I'd be
hitting the the B Pawn so black wouldn't
have time to take on
D4 but Bishop H5 I'm probably the best
move I still have to choose like do I
want to play Bishop E2 do I want to play
Bishop
C4 another
option which is kind of interesting here
is to play Pawn
G4 it's way more aggressive would
provoke Bishop
G6 and then go for Knight
E5 and the idea would be
to set up Bishop F4 to more easily
exploit the
queen I think I'll go for that and this
is not the most conventional way of
playing
but uh I think it's a nice example of
when it can make sense to break
principles cuz very often I mean at
least from a beginner level you're
usually told not to push the pawns too
far on your king side especially if you
plan to Castle rule number three don't
push your kingside pawns uh but because
I haven't committed to castling yet then
I can basically afford to expand and
then probably later plan to Castle Queen
side I'm curious here maybe black is
considering to take get two pawns for
the
knight uh very often this is not worth
sacrificing the Knight for
black so Bishop G6 I mean should be the
move to play
here but yeah my opponent's taking
time I mean I will say that if takes and
then takes and then takes I'll I'll be
very content to play Bishop E2 and
Bishop E3 and just be very solid and
then then have some files to work with
on the king
side so we do see Bishop
G6 and yeah I mentioned this move Knight
E5 I'm going to play it right away and
this also breaks another principle
moving the same piece twice in the
opening before completing
development but I think this move is
Justified cuz I I really want to find
the optimal Square for the Starks for
Bishop and once I play Bishop
F4 now I'm setting up some nasty
discoveries uh mainly threatening Knight
takes G6 to attack the queen and defend
the bishop and attack The
Rook so black does have to be very very
careful
here another benefit with advancing the
G Pawn is now I do have the G2 Square
for this bishop so it's very likely I'll
play Bishop to G2 and then Target The
Pawn on
B7 and from Black's perspective I mean
yeah I was going to say that black
should probably move the queen queen E7
it's kind of a safe move but it's an
ugly move to play because it's keeping
the bishop on f8 blocked
in now I don't think I can punish this
move directly so I think the best
approach is just to keep developing
Bishop G2
attacking
upon yeah C6 so black is um it's kind of
curling up into a ball here a little bit
on the king
side it's not easy to crack I mean I'm
considering a move like Knight C4 to set
up Knight to
D6 but yeah with Knight C4 I think black
could easily just play Queen D7 or queen
d8 and then prepare to develop the
bishop and prevent Knight
D6
so there's a few other moves that come
to
mind I think the simplest moves would be
Queen D2 or queen
E2 and then then decide later which side
I want to Castle on there is another
idea here to play Pawn H4 to expand on
the king side and actually threaten to
trap the
bishop and going back to this this whole
plan of H3 G4 I mean this is one of the
long-term plans is to to keep gaining
space I'm going to play H4 cuz I don't
see an obvious move for black to save
the bishop and black just very quickly
plays Knight
D7 uh move like H6 or H5 would have
allowed Knight takes G6 and then black
would have very bad structure so here
and if I play
H5 I think I'm winning material if black
takes I take back and then the Knight
and Bishop will be attacked meanwhile
I'm controlling all these squares where
the bishop can
move so let's go for
H5 yeah Bishop takes
C2 my opponent has all of a sudden been
playing a lot more quickly the last few
moves maybe going on
tilt but uh yeah still have
to to stay focused here KN has won the
G4
Pawn um I can't trap the Knight like
F3 it would force the Knight back to
H6 I don't think it's it's worth playing
F3 just
now um yeah what to do I could Castle
get the Rook to the
dile also Knight E4 looks nice to go
into
D6 Knight E4 might allow Queen
B4
which maybe I don't want to deal
with so yeah I'm going to go ahead and
Castle queenside here uh just getting
the king to safety F2 is defended by my
queen so no worries about the Knight
winning
material and nice thing about casting
queenside is I'm preventing black from
casting queenside because I'm
controlling the d8 square King can't
Castle through
check so Queen C5 is played this does
attack F2 and E5 so the the Knight and
queen are both targeting a couple
different weak
pawns the first move that comes to mind
is Knight E4 just offering the queen
trade also keeping F2
defended I like this nice and simple if
we trade Queens then yeah then the
position should just be easier to play
and yeah black is not winning the F2
Pawn still can Castle Queen side at some
point I might want to consider Knight D6
but I don't want to do it too soon
because uh yeah F2 would hang and end of
that line so maybe now's the time to
play
F3 attacking the
Knight forcing it back to H6 if if black
wants to save the Knight
and then then I can probably simplify
further take the
Knight this bishop this bishop wants to
find a life from
G2 uh so let's play
F4 just a nice move to give the bishop
some more
scope and generally when there's a
situation with obst Bishops then I
definitely want my pawns on the opposite
color of my
Bishop not only to harmonize with my
bishop and control more squares but also
to restrict the Pawn's Bishop pawns do a
nice job of yeah preventing this Bishop
from doing
anything so black plays Rook d8 uh
offering The Rook
trade yeah I'm happy to trade here and
take and I'll get the Rook to the
defile and going forward from here it
still takes a bit of work to to convert
the material advantage
and it feels like my pieces are pretty
optimized for the most part but
um this position requires a plan going
forward and I'm looking at this move
Knight D6 just to facilitate some more
trades and if takes I can
take although the I think the issue with
Knight D6 is after takes takes King D7
the pawn might be more of a liability
than a strength CU it's very hard to
actually keep advancing the pawn
so what else can I consider here Knight
F6 comes to
mind actually don't see anything like so
obvious to do I'm going to play a
waiting move here A3 this seems like a
very slow move speaking of slow I do
have to manage my time but the idea is
to Simply expand on the queen side
probably soon I want to get my king to a
better square at least a more active
square and I'm sort of playing the
waiting game
[Music]
um I should note here that box Rook
can't enter my territory because I'm
controlling all these squares with
Knight and Bishop and
pawns and I think the waiting game is
now paying off because with this move
King B6 the king is no longer
controlling
D7 and The Rook is
infiltrated the bishop is uh is almost
stuck there I'm actually very close to a
mating that if I get to play play this
move and this move it would be
checkmates of course the bishop could
take maybe now's the time for Knight
D6 it's so nice having the rook in
Black's
territory now F7 is a
target yeah let's take on
H7 I might be losing the pawn like D7
King
C7 okay let's go for
[Music]
D7 if black wants to win the pawn then
then we'll trade
Rooks and yeah now we have an example of
uh why it's nice to have an extra Bishop
in the end
game and with with so many pawns on
light spares they're they're going to
fall off um yeah one by one so opponent
resigns yeah that was a an interesting
game definitely of an unorthodox idea
from the opening I mean it's so common
to see this situation especially
emerging from the scandavian and I think
the Scandinavian is one opening where
it's more common to go for this H3 G4
expansion um to just try and gain space
on the king side and then try and
exploit the queen which has developed
early and I think my opponent's biggest
mistake in this game was just not
identifying the threat of trapping the
bishop uh they played this move Knight
D7 in less than two seconds um black
should have been aware of what I want to
do and yeah probably should have played
a move like H6 or H5 of course it would
have allowed me to take and then take
and the structure is good for white I
would keep initiative but um yeah it's
still playable for black like Knight D5
and the game would go
on so hopefully some lessons to take
away from that one let's do one more
hopefully break uh rating of
1250 so we'll keep it going playing
Stefon
mzi and this time I'm black and I'll
play another king
PA so all three games so far in this
episode featuring Kings Pawn
opening actually yeah the last game was
a scandavian but all all three games
featuring E4 on move one um this time we
have a scotch opening and uh yeah the
best move here is to take there's really
no other good
alternative and this position the the
two main moves are Knight F6 and Bishop
C5 I'll play Bishop C5 here this is what
I've been playing the idea is to Simply
pressure the
knights very often white will eventually
play
C3 um the main line here is is Bishop to
E3 and then I can play Queen F6 to
provoke C3 but there are other options
for White's position there's Knight B3
there's Knight takes
C6 Knight F5 might even be a
move so opponent taking
time a lot of the players who play the
scotch will like keep moving quickly
after Bishop
C5 because it is one of the most common
moves wow we do see KN F5 so yeah I have
a vague memory of like seeing this as a
like surprise weapon at some point but I
don't know if this is like the exact
position I've seen before of course this
move attacks the G7 Pawn uh the drawback
of this move for white is like White's
not developing anything they're they're
just moving the same piece
again so ideally I'd like
to to accelerate my own development of
course I have to
figure out what to do about G7 I'm
considering G6 and if Knight G7 then I
can just play King f8 and trap the
Knight other move that comes to mind is
Queen F6 to defend and then align with
the F
Pawn I think between Queen F6 or G6 both
of these seem like fine
choices I'll be a bit more aggressive
and play Queen
F6 cuz very often in the scotch um black
does like to bring the queen out to
pressure D4 in this case I um I defend
G7 and also try and uh align with F2
Pawn so I think it's very likely that G6
will come soon or maybe just Knight E7
to keep developing the Knight is
somewhat pinned to the pawn and I say
somewhat pinned because uh the Knight
could move to
E3 where it would block the bishop and
uh and be
okay but Knight C3 is played so yeah
this is a good move from White uh
threatening Knight to D5 I do have to be
careful because Knight D5 would
be very very annoying attacking the
queen and attacking
C7
so yeah I'm inclined here to play Knight
E7 to just keep an eye on D5 and also
pressure the nland
F5 I don't see anything wrong with this
I mean white has to make sure not to
blunder Maiden one like if Knight takes
E7 this would be
Checkmate and meanwhile I'm probably
threatening to take the knights and then
takes and takes and I would win a pawn
there so yeah I'm curious what White's
going to play here I don't see an easy
response
for white to make in this
position I mean maybe a move like Bishop
D3 is uh the most useful developing
preparing to Castle and supporting
F5 and if we see Bishop D3 I think my
plan going forward is to I was going to
say is to complete my own development
but we see Knight D5 so yeah I think I'm
pretty much obliged to take the
Knight like moving the queen I don't
think would make sense
there and now white can take with the
pawn or the queen
uh if takes with Pawn I would have taken
and hit F2 so yeah Queen takes D5
definitely the the better
option and now I'll just play
D6 defending the bishop preparing to
bring out my own bishop and material
still equal but um I think this has been
a slightly preferable opening for black
yeah having a bit more development nice
central
control Bishop C4 it's a active
developing move but I think this is
actually the biggest blunder for
white so far this
game because once Bishop E6 happens the
queen has one square to move back to to
keep the bishop
defended um and after Queen
D3 I'll have a nice tactic to win
material um or so I think that I should
actually uh just make sure here but
yeah Knight E5 works the queen and
Bishop now there is Bishop B5 but then I
have C6 and I think everything is under
control there there's Knight takes D6
but then after Bishop takes D6 Queen
takes Z6 I'll win the bishop in the end
yeah let's go for
this so yeah white kind of fell victim
there at uh just having the queen out in
my territory where it was uh very easy
to
exploit now my opponent probably
realizing the
consequences so From mik's perspective
here like the probably the best try is
to play Bishop B5 to try and
Counterattack and muddy the waters but
yeah with
C6 still attacking the bishop still
attacking the queen and we do see Knight
D6 okay so yeah white white is trying to
Counterattack uh but I'll take of course
I'd love to take on F2 but I'm in check
so have to get rid of the
Knight and now I can take the
bishop so manag to win a minor piece for
a
pawn I do want to give kudos to my
opponent for probably finding what was
the best line there to at least try and
get some
compensation and with the queen on D6 I
can't Castle either way uh fortunate I
can play Rook d8 try and get the queen
away and hopefully Castle
[Music]
soon Queen C7 okay so this does attack
B7 I don't think I mind giving away the
pawn but I'm going to take a moment here
cuz I mean I'm very very inclined to
just start attacking on the king side
like even a move as move Knight F3 comes
to mind it takes and then Queen G6
doesn't quite work because yeah the
queen can come back yeah I think I'll
just uh allow white to take the pawn get
the king safe get my Rooks
connected and then focus on attacking
later on I mean yeah the Knight bishop
and queen do have a lot of potential on
on the queen side on the king side I
should
say there's going to be ideas of like
Queen H4 Knight
G4 maybe still some potential sacrifices
as
[Music]
well so I'm actually realizing here
there there's a really really fancy
line
um I opponent did give me some time to
think there and yeah there's there's a
line that um
I want to calculate because it starts
with Knight F3 and after takes I play
Queen G6 and because the queen has taken
on B7 it can't come back to defend the
king would have to move to
H1 and then I play Bishop H3 threatening
mate let me just clean the arrows and
reiterate so Knight F3 takes Queen G6
King
H1 Bishop H3
the only way for white to defend the
checkmates is Rook
G1 and then I have Rook to
D1 and is that
winning ah there might be Bishop G5
there Bishop G5 I take and then take
yeah that that might be um not quite
working feels close though and there's
also Knight of3 takes and then
takes does why have any way to stop the
mates ah there's Queen C7 and queen can
come
back yeah like Knight of three it's a
move
that I'm very very tempted to
play
but I think it it's too much of a risk
and it's really not necessary here I'm
going to play uh this move Bishop to C4
which keeps things way more controlled
um defending the pawn and also attacking
The Rook
sometimes this is one of my weaknesses
is uh kind of tunneling down the funny
lines oh no my opponent uh opponent
making life very easy there okay so
Bishop C4 worked out well I wonder if
that could have been a mouse slip like
maybe opponent intended Rook e one or
maybe just didn't quite see the
connection of the Rooks on the
defile but uh again hopefully some
lessons to take away from this game
opponent got in trouble uh pretty early
on after violating some opening
principles so I think I'll wrap it up
there um thanks everyone for watching if
you like the content subscribe if you
have questions leave them below and I'll
see you guys soon for episode 25 stay
tuned